[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm honored to host
Paul English and Tracy Kidder.
We're here talking about
that Tracy's recent book--
"A Truck Full of Money,"
which is a fantastic book.
And I want to start
off with Tracy.
Tracy can you talk about the
research process involved
for making this book?
TRACY KIDDER: Yeah.
Most of it was
following Paul around,
which meant sometimes taking
six o'clock in the morning
trains from South Station
or red eyes from California
back to Boston.
It was interesting.
It was fun.
It was pretty much the
way I do it all the time.
I mean, I've done
it now for-- I don't
know how many years-- 30
some years, 35, 36 years.
I try to be a good
guest in person's life.
He can tell you
whether I was or not.
But I--
PAUL ENGLISH: Usually.
TRACY KIDDER: Yeah.
Hang around.
So I think of that as
the primary research.
I started this with a
curiosity about what
had happened to the world of the
digital in the last 35 years.
Because back in the
early 80s, I published--
I watched a team of
computer engineers
build a new computer
back in Massachusetts.
And I left that subject
as fast as I could,
just because I wanted to
see the rest of the world.
And that book, because it was,
to many people's surprise,
including mine, a
success, I wanted
to make use of that
success by exploring
the rest of the world.
I did that for 30 some years.
But then I got sort of curious
as to what had happened,
or thought anyway it
might be fun to look into.
And I knew Paul from Partners
in Health-- Dr. Paul Farmer's
organization-- and asked
him to show me around.
And after a while,
I thought, well,
my guide should be my subject
as well, partly because
at least at that
time, it seemed to me
his career spanned a very big
segment of the digital age.
I mean, really late
in the development
of the personal
computer to now--
and also his experience has been
pretty broad-- and a programmer
and a manager of programmers
and an entrepreneur,
starting his own companies.
But as time went on, I got--
I think of it as looking
for a window on this world.
And it was an
interesting window.
The view was interesting,
but I found the window
more interesting than the view.
So I did different
kinds of research.
I'd go out and talk to
people who'd known Paul
and talk to experts in
various departments.
Paul's life is pretty varied.
So I ended up
learning a fair amount
about things like bipolar
disorder and myasthenia gravis,
which your mom had, as well
as trying to learn something
about the World Wide Web.
I had the great privilege
during all of this
to interview Donald Knuth.
It was really the-- I
think a lot of people
would say-- they might call
him the progenitor of computer
science.
That wouldn't be entirely
fair, but he organized.
And the first volumes of "The
Art of Computer Programming"
seems to have pulled
together the best that
was known and
thought at the time,
including some of
what he had done.
He's still working on
it-- fascinating guy.
And I was going to tell
you-- this is completely
off the subject-- but
it was wonderful for me
to talk to him.
I enjoyed reading him immensely.
Not "The Art of
Computer Programming,"
which was not meant for
the likes of me-- but he
writes really lucidly on
interesting philosophical
subjects.
There's a book that
I highly recommend,
if you don't know it, called
"Things that a Computer
Scientist Rarely Talks About."
And he's quite religious.
He has fascinating takes on God.
And one of his many
published interviews
that people have with him,
he uses the word geeks.
This is one of my
favorite things about it.
He says, just sake of
brevity, let's say people
like me are geeks.
And we are 2% of the population.
And he goes on to
explain that in his view,
it's probable that
the people who
built the pyramids years
ago-- the 2% of them--
would have been great
computer programmers,
if there had been
computers at the time.
So computer programming,
the great gift for it,
was probably something
he thinks in-born,
awaiting its instrument.
And he has some empirical
evidence of that.
Anyway, I don't know
how I got off on that.
But the term geek is
interesting to me,
because like so many of these
words that were really nasty--
a geek I think once
referred to these guys that
would play wild men in
those traveling caravan
things around the country.
And as for nerd-- nerd and
geek are now terms of praise,
often used by people who call
themselves nerds and geeks.
I'm a basketball nerd.
Anyway, I got off the subject.
But that's one of the
great things about my job,
is that I get to
talk to such people.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And I noticed that
Donald Knuth's book
is like 2,200 pages long.
TRACY KIDDER: Well, he's
working-- as I understand it,
I think it's volume four.
He's been on that a long time.
I think volume four has
several-- five volumes already.
But it's tough because he's
been writing about algorithms.
I met him because of
a close old friend
of named Carl Barry, who is
one of the people who helps
to maintain the program tech.
It was a lot of fun.
SPEAKER 1: So behind the
name, "A Truck Full of Money,"
what inspired that?
TRACY KIDDER: There's a story.
Some of the people
here know this guy--
Bill O'Donnell-- a very fine
programmer indeed-- lovely guy.
When Bill O'Donnell left
Kayak, the engineers
stood and gave him
a standing ovation.
That's, I'm told, very, very
rare in a world of computer
engineers.
Some years before, Billo and
Paul Schwenk and Jeff Rago
had all taken a break
from Paul, and had started
their own little company.
It wasn't doing very well.
They had nobody really
to sell their product.
And Paul came to visit them
in their shabby little office,
and he said, I'm
starting something new.
This is well before
Kayak-- long before.
And they said, well,
we'll think about it.
And Paul left, and Bill
and Rago and Schwenk all
remember this story
exactly the same way.
They said, well--
Rago and Schwenk said,
we'd like to sort
of keep trying.
We think this still might work.
And Billo said, look, guys,
I feel bad about this.
You can have all my stock,
but I'm going to go with Paul.
And then he felt it was
necessary to explain.
He said, because
someday, this boy
is going to get hit by
a truck full of money
and I'm going to be
standing beside him.
And he was actually
when Kayak was sold.
And also he was standing there
after Boston Light was sold.
And Paul took his share
of the $33.5 million
and divide it in half and
distribute it to the employees.
People remember
that sort of thing.
But I meant the title
with some irony,
because I think that the
year-- several years that I
spent with Paul-- I think
were difficult years for him.
And I think it's
difficult sometimes
to recover from a great success.
I suppose there was something
autobiographical about that
in my mind, because I
do remember when I wrote
"The Soul of a New Machine."
I was only 34 years old.
And suddenly, I was given the
Pulitzer Prize and the National
Book Award, and I
got very confused.
I drank a lot.
I just found it
difficult. I was suddenly
separated from all my brethren--
all my writer friends.
So I was on the
lookout for this.
And I think Paul
was casting around,
looking for things to do--
the right things to do.
What am I saying?
Anyway, a truck
is-- I know Billo
meant that in a very casual
way-- the truck full of money.
That's just meaning
a lot of money.
But I thought of
the actual truck
as something that hits you.
I meant it with a bit of irony
because I don't think-- the one
thing I think-- my way of
thinking that Paul isn't, is
meretricious.
He's not tremendously
materialistic,
except about cars.
SPEAKER 1: So winning the
Pulitzer in your early 30s--
I mean many authors wait their
whole entire lives to get
an opportunity.
A lot don't get it.
So what did it feel like to hit
such a grand accomplishment?
TRACY KIDDER: It was
a little daunting.
I was elated at first.
I couldn't believe it.
And then I did
have writer friends
who ceased to be
friends-- were so envious.
I probably would have been
the same in their place.
It was strange.
I was pretty young--
even young for my age--
just barely out of adolescence,
possibly-- I don't know.
A lot of young men are I think.
One of the things
is you really want
to believe, when you
get a prize like that,
that you deserved it.
It's sort of like
being an American
and having quite a lot of
privilege, and thinking, well,
I've earned my privileges.
But in my case, I was a
judge for the Pulitzer's
later and also for the
National Book Award.
And what you realize is that
usually those prizes are given
to-- you have a committee.
And pretty much
everything-- the prize goes
to everybody's third choice.
[LAUGHTER]
But I did meet the guy who
had been-- a wonderful writer
really-- who had
been my champion.
At least he told me--
I forget how I met him.
He was a wonderful writer
named Paul Fussell.
And he said, you owe me a drink.
I said why?
He said, I was your
advocate for the Pulitzer.
And I said, I'll
buy you two drinks.
SPEAKER 1: Well, when
you talked about winning
the Pulitzer and your feeling
very humble towards it
because it's such an honor.
TRACY KIDDER: I wasn't humble.
On the contrary--
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Well,
it's interesting
because when Paul sold Kayak,
he was told by a lot of people
how great he was.
And then Paul said to
himself, I didn't actually
work that hard, he thought.
I'm just good at something
that makes a lot of money.
TRACY KIDDER: Yeah.
If there was one
thing Paul told me,
or one thought that I
overheard the whole time I
was with him, that's the one
I think would stick with me.
If there was just going to
be one that stuck with me.
Because it strikes me as true
and unusually honest and open.
And unusual too
probably for some
of the people in
this general area
who have made great fortunes.
I do think we tend to feel
in America that making
huge amounts of money is almost
an apotheosis in itself--
both evidence and just
reward for one's superiority.
And I'm not necessarily
blaming the tycoons,
though some of them I
suppose do buy into it.
And it's even more extreme
because this is technology.
And so one gets the
feeling, these people
are masters of the
future, as well as
the present-- the vertebral
Darwins and Newtons.
It gets quite excessive
like so many things.
But I don't think
Paul ever bought
into that cultural grandiosity.
SPEAKER 1: So what's one of your
favorite stories from the book?
TRACY KIDDER: A lot of them.
I like them all.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
TRACY KIDDER: I like the
story that the book begins
with of his going to
Boston Latin School
and learning how to-- inventing
for himself the fishing
to get the control of attendance
so that he could play hooky
for the next six years.
It probably has set him back a
ways in his professional life.
But the one I really
like a lot, and I
think it's really
interesting, is that time
when you felt you'd
been fired, and you
were in a deep, deep
depression-- partly, no doubt,
from bipolar.
And he latched on to the
idea of doing something
with Chinese chess, and
ended up making this-- along
with Carl Barry, just
the two of them--
making this really
for its time, quite
remarkable elaborate website.
A regular xiangqi palace--
Chinese chess palace,
where you could go and you
can watch other people play.
And you could kibbitz.
And the second most
popular board game,
I guess in the world--
and I liked the fact
that what Paul--
the way I understood
the story-- I think
you would agree--
is that he coded his
way out of depression,
which is quite remarkable.
I mean it's much better
than languishing in it.
SPEAKER 1: It's true.
I've noticed in
American history,
we go through generations
of wealth creation.
And for the longest time
in American history,
wealth was handed down from
one generation to the next.
And now we're seeing
people such as Paul,
who comes from
humble beginnings,
now coming into wealth.
So I'm wondering-- your
humble beginnings in Boston--
how did affect your
success in tech?
PAUL ENGLISH: So I grew up
in a working class family.
My dad was a pipefitter.
He worked for the same
company for 49 years.
And my mother was
a social worker.
And I grew up in
a family of nine.
We had a three bedroom
house with one bathroom
so it was pretty modest.
Well, first of all, when I
would see people who had money,
I just thought of them as
just a foreign species.
I thought moneyed people
were very different
than my family and me.
I have this funny thing, to this
day, when I get on the shuttle
to New York from Boston,
where I live now,
and I see all these guys get
on the plane wearing suits,
I actually get uncomfortable
with people wearing suits.
It's just something
bizarre about it.
I don't quite understand
it-- but the whole prestige
and power, particularly
people who work in finance,
just feels very foreign
and uncomfortable to me.
The guys I hang out most
with now in Boston--
there's a group of six of us.
And we've been playing poker
since we were 12-years-old.
And one of them--
[INAUDIBLE] is a landscaper.
Bob's a plumber.
Arthur's a
manufacturing engineer.
Andrew's in IT guy.
Ray is a marketing guy.
It's like my comfort zone--
just kind of like normal guys.
And a lot of times in
tech, even though I
love team building and
design and customer support,
the business part of tech
is something I actually
have very little interest in.
SPEAKER 1: Now, the
business aspect of tech,
did you partner with
Schwenk in Kayak?
Did he handle those aspects and
did you mostly handle the day
to day engineering operations?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
So my Kayak co-founder is
a guy named Steve Haffner.
Steve was one of
the founders Orbitz.
And the idea for
Kayak actually came
in a conversation
between Steve Haffner
and one of our investors, Joe
Kotler at General Catalyst.
And the two of them,
with Steve leaving
Orbitz, which was, what I would
describe as a travel store,
they basically came up with the
idea of creating a pure search
engine where nothing is sold,
but every product is indexed.
And in 2004 when
we created Kayak,
there was no one
website that had
every single flight
and every single hotel,
like Expedia for
example-- and to this day,
will only show hotels where
they make a commission.
They don't show you every hotel.
And so Kayak-- I think there
were two things we focused on.
One is making sure we had more
inventory than anyone else.
Even if people didn't pay us,
we had them on the website.
We were really obsessed.
And we showed their
actual phone number,
their actual website address--
just complete transparency.
And then the second
thing we focused on--
that I focused on at Kayak
was-- I saw other travel sites
at the time as bloatware.
They were big and innovative
graphics and slow.
And it was shocking to me
how it would take 45 seconds
to find a flight.
So we begin this quest,
which I worked on
for 10 years, which was how to
do something that wasn't faster
than Expedia, but was shockingly
different because it was
so much faster than Expedia.
So we were the first guys to
do subsecond search for travel
across every vertical.
It was non-trivial
to build that,
because we're sitting on top
of systems that are themselves
decades old.
But yeah, we wanted to be full
inventory and really fast.
SPEAKER 1: You mentioned when
you had your start at Boston
Light, after you
guys were acquired,
you came across a
sizable equity valuation.
There were certain
people who weren't
receiving as much money.
And you decided to
spread that money around.
What was going through your mind
when you decided to do that?
PAUL ENGLISH:
Usually, every time I
do an M&A deal, whether I'm
buying a company, to become
part of my company, or
looking at selling a company--
and I've sold I think
five real companies.
Four were successful.
One, I lost $2 million
which was very painful.
It was a time in my life where
I just made money and then lost
it.
But when I look at
selling companies,
I actually never have done
the math, even at Kayak,
about how much money
I was going to make.
But I knew how much
money my assistant made.
I knew how much stock
people had on my team who
didn't have very much stock.
And even for a new company
Lola, we're only a year old.
So it's crazy, crazy premature
to even think about exit value.
Hopefully that's many
years away because I
like running companies
independently as long as I can.
But when it comes time to try
to find an exit for Lola, I'm
going to try to figure out,
can my assistant buy a house?
And I have a lot more
stock than she has.
So if she can buy a
house, I'll probably
be able to buy a lot
of houses-- not that I
would buy a lot of houses.
But it just, to me,
it seems to make sense
to think about a
company in terms
of how would a
financial outcome impact
the people who have the
least amount in the company?
So I don't know why
I think like that.
But I know how many
shares my assistant has.
I know how many shares my travel
agents have who work at Lola,
my new company.
And I would like to make sure
they all do well financially.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
I mean it's really
hard to determine
how you're going
to spread the cap
table at the beginning
of the venture
when you don't know how
things are going to play out.
PAUL ENGLISH: Exactly.
SPEAKER 1: Now, it seems like
your mentor, Thomas White,
inspired some of your thoughts
towards charitable work
and also towards
running businesses.
Can you explain his
impact on your life to us?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
So Tom is a guy that I met back
in, I want to say about 2000.
He was the uncle of a
childhood friend of mine.
And I had sold a company,
Boston Light to it.
I made a bunch of money.
I wanted to give away
most of the money I made.
So I call this guy Tom White.
He was 80 years old at the time.
And I asked him if
he could teach me how
to give away money efficiently.
And I remember
one funny story is
I did a little bit of research
on him before I met him.
And I learned that the biggest
beneficiary of his work
was his doctor, Paul
Farmer, who had created
this organization called
Partners in Health,
and I serve on the board now.
And when I met Tom,
I said, I understand
that Partners in Health
has raised $30 million
for Haiti to help
with health care.
And he is very proud of that.
And then I said, but I heard
that $20 million of that
came from you personally.
You probably think that
makes you a good person.
I think it makes you a
really shitty fundraiser.
And then I worked
with Tom on trying
to figure out how to make
him more highly leveraged.
Because he made about $100
million over his career--
was an estimate.
He had told me once.
And he told me that his
plan was to die penniless,
with owning no possessions.
And so I kind of
have the same goal,
that I want to die with nothing.
I don't die with
nothing, but I want
to die-- I want to have a bed.
I probably want to have
whatever the iPhone 56 is,
a Kindle, and a clock radio.
And I think that's
pretty much all I need.
TRACY KIDDER: You're sick.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Now, can you talk about your
idea generation process?
Because it seems like you're
just constantly coming up
with new ideas and new ventures.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I actually teach
entrepreneurship at MIT
and I lecture on
entrepreneurship
at a pretty diverse
set of universities.
I lecture at Rhode
Island School of Design,
which is phenomenal
design school on the East
Coast, Berklee College of
Music, Dartmouth Film School.
And I really enjoy
focusing on innovation
in industries outside of
tech and trying to figure out
how you encapsulate innovation.
Like what are the key elements
that make something new?
And the work that I've
done across those multiple
industries has taught me,
the most important thing
to do as an innovator is to
pick the right problems to fix.
And if you confront a problem
that really bothers you-- that
bothers you so much that
you can imagine spending
five years of your life
working on the problem,
and it's also a problem
that bothers millions
of other people, if you
find the right problem
and it's a real
problem that is causing
serious issues for people,
then all you need to do
is lock on to it, hire
an exceptional team
and just keep trying stuff.
And most likely the first thing
you do won't be successful.
But if you've picked
the right problem
and you're committed to solving
it, eventually you will.
So the advice I
give to my students
is become problem detectors
before they become solution.
A lot of entrepreneurs, when
they look to raise money,
they pitch what they've
built. I, as an investor,
am less interested in
what they've built.
What I'm interested
in is the team
and what problem
they're trying to solve,
because the initial solution is
usually not the final solution.
Being a problem detector means,
if you're really good at it--
and I think it's something
you can practice,
just like you can
practice mindfulness--
being a problem
detector means you
look at all kinds
of problems in life.
So I remember I gave
a lecture on this
at Dartmouth Film School.
And there was a girl
sitting in the front,
and she had a Dunkin'
Donuts coffee cup.
And the Dunkin' Donuts--
you flip the top back.
And sometimes when you're
drinking the coffee,
the thing flips up and
hits you in the nose.
I don't know if anyone's
ever experienced that.
And I had asked her, when
I saw that coffee cup,
has that ever flipped up
and hit you in the nose?
She said, yeah, it has.
And everyone kind of got a
big laugh in the audience.
And I said, well, why haven't
you done anything about it?
And since then, people
invented coffee cups
that you just turn-- you just
spin it and two holes line up.
I think it's just,
notice a problem.
If the problem really,
really bothers you,
just keep thinking up
solutions, solutions, solutions.
I'll tell you an
example of something
that bothered me today as we're
walking around San Francisco.
I am bothered by noise.
And I'm really bothered by car
horns and rudeness of car horns
when drivers beep overly
aggressively at people
for not necessarily
doing something bad.
And so I always think
of solutions like,
how can I have less beeping?
And a couple of solutions
that a few of us
talked about this week is one,
what if you made a regulation
that there was a car horn placed
inside the passenger cabin
as well as under the hood?
Another one is, what if you
had the steering wheel give
a minor electric shock?
So you still could
beep the horn but there
would be a little bit
of payback in doing it.
So yeah, to me
innovation is about when
you see something that is
wrong, just obsess on it,
and say, I don't know the answer
yet but I know this is wrong
and I know I'm going to
find a solution to it.
SPEAKER 1: Gotcha.
Instead of trying to
sell a solution-- trying
to find a problem.
Find the problem and
build the solution for it.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You mentioned
how important it
is to have a team around you.
I've noticed
through your career,
you have these people
called 20 plussers
who have been around with
you for 20 plus more years.
Can you explain how
that came to happen?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I don't think it was
explicitly intentional.
Back like when I cut my
Bos Light stock in half,
so I could dilute everyone else
up so everyone else could get
much more of the company, I
wasn't explicitly thinking
then, I'm doing
this so these people
will be with me for 20 years.
I think that was one of
the things that contributed
to people following me
company to company--
is they saw that I
treated people well.
But I'm just someone who values
longevity in relationships.
And I don't know how much
this has to do with my family,
growing up in a small
house with nine people.
But the fact that, again, I
still hang out with these guys
and we've been playing
cards since we were 12,
I just value long-term
relationships.
And I think that if you
create a work environment
that's really fun and where
people really like each other,
and where you debug-- I
probably spend 5% of my time
as a psychologist, where
I observe body language.
And I try to find things in my
company that aren't working,
and where is stress.
And I try to eliminate that.
And I name it and then
bring people together
and say, Hugh, how come you
interrupt Cathy all the time?
Or whatever it is, I'll try to--
SPEAKER 2: That's one way
to get a word in edgewise.
[LAUGHTER]
CATHY: It's the
other way around.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I think if you spend
a lot of time trying
to make sure the team dynamic
is really, really strong,
people will love their job.
They'll help recruit more
people and they'll probably
stay there for years.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Can you explain-- like
you mentioned your family
growing up and there's
nine people living
in a three bedroom house.
In the book, it
mentioned that your job
was to make people feel happy.
Did that psychology
also influence
your business practices?
PAUL ENGLISH: I never thought
of it exactly like that,
but no one ever
assigned me to be
that peacemaker in my college.
My dad was a drinker and
we had strife in my home.
I don't know why I
became the peacemaker,
but I took on that role.
And when anyone in my
family was in crisis,
I'm the one that they call
to help manage situations.
Like I have a brother with a
brain injury that I manage.
I host a family dinner
every Tuesday night.
And I organize my
business travels
so every Tuesday night
I can be home to cook.
And my siblings all come over
and a 90-year-old neighbor
comes over.
So I think-- yeah, I
think problem solving
is all about maintaining
relationships.
Like in my small house I grew
up in, because it was congested,
if someone was drunk
or angry or fighting,
it caused strife
across the whole family
that rippled across and
everyone could feel it.
If instead, you could debug
that and try to figure out
how to alleviate some of
the stress in the family,
it made it a happier
place for everyone.
And I that's true in
the workplace as well.
I've always promised people who
have come to work and for me
that I will make this the best
place they've ever worked.
And I'll make them more
productive than they've ever
been.
And I take those comments
pretty seriously.
And if I promise
someone that I'll
make this the best place
they've ever worked,
and yet they're sitting
next to someone who's
kind of an asshole and
cause a lot of stress,
I'm going to fail
on my commitment.
So I need to debug
that and figure out
why are two people
not getting along.
So I guess the
peacemaker part of me
that grew up in this family--
large family in a small house--
translated into
in the work, I try
to be a bit of a
peacemaker as well.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
And you also mentioned
that because there
are so many things
going on in your house,
one constant would be
being able to program.
And that sort of gave kind
of consistency and an escape.
Do you find that
the main driving
passion for you to code--
or were there other things
involved that pushed
you towards computers?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I always took work
pretty seriously.
And part of it was work
was a way for me to have
an identity outside the house.
Inside the house, it
felt very controlled,
and outside the house so you
could form your own identity,
get your own job,
make your own money.
And I remember, I was
making minimum wage,
which back when I
was in high school,
I think was $2.65 an hour.
And I worked at a drugstore
at the Dedham Mall
outside of Boston.
And I remember one
time on a Friday night,
we used to go out
drinking after work.
I think I was 16 at the time.
And I remember always having
a pizza, a bottle of wine,
and then maybe smoking some
weed or other things like that.
And I woke up one
Saturday morning really,
really, really hangover.
But it wouldn't ever crossed my
mind to call in sick to work.
And I think I was still so hung
over that I couldn't drive,
even though I had owned a car.
So I took a taxi to work.
And my father was
furious when he found out
that I would spend
money on a taxi.
But I got to work and
I worked that day.
And to me, I was
just always proud
of forming your identity
outside of home and work
as a part of that.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
And then also you worked
while going to school
at the same time,
taking night classes.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I worked full-time in college.
I actually didn't
apply to college.
I wanted to be a musician.
And I went to a very
good high school,
one of the best schools
in the country-- in fact,
Boston Latin, founded in 1635.
And I tested at
the top of the city
for getting into that
school but I graduated
at the bottom of a class.
30 of my classmates got
accepted to Harvard,
so it's a really
good high school.
And I didn't apply to college.
I was just going
to be a musician.
And then my parents
found out I could
go to a state school for
free because I aced my SATs.
I test well.
And the only state school I
could get into at that point
was UMass Boston.
And lucky for me, they
had an amazing jazz band.
So I wrote for a 15-piece
band and then worked full-time
as a programmer and
went to school at night.
It took me five years to
get my bachelor's degree,
but then I stayed on two more
years to get my Masters degree
and I ended up teaching there.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Now, going to night classes,
you see a different crowd
of people.
So you're probably with
more adults, and veterans.
Did that influence you too?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I remember taking a class and we
were studying the Vietnam War.
And the guy on my
right was a vet
in a wheelchair,
injured from the war.
And then the guy
sitting in front of me
had lost his son in the war.
They were debating
the morality of war.
And I remember thinking like
my friends going to Harvard
are not having this experience
that I'm having right now.
So there were certain advantages
of being in a poor commuter
school, that you
got to experience
different cross-sections
of the city
that you might otherwise not, if
I just stayed-- if I went down
like an Ivy League path.
It's kind of like last year,
I drove Uber for a while.
And I really loved
that because--
SPEAKER 1: In your Audi, right?
PAUL ENGLISH: In
my Tesla, actually.
SPEAKER 1: Oh your Tesla.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And that
was an UberX ride too?
That's quite a deal.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
And I really enjoyed it.
I did it for research
for my company--
for my new company,
Lola-- as something
that I wanted to learn
about around ratings.
But I was also surprised to
learn that my world is actually
quite narrow.
In Boston, generally
the only people
that have communication
with are my family,
people who work in
tech or people who
work in Haiti,
because that's where
I spend most of my time--
in those three areas.
And driving Uber
around, I got to meet
all kinds of crazy people
who lived in Boston.
And it reminded me
of my college days,
where it just was a very,
very diverse set of people.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And you learn more about
yourself in that process,
don't you?
PAUL ENGLISH: I think so, yeah.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, one
of my best experiences
going through was
community college,
and I worked while going
to community college.
And I just met so
many different people
at different walks of life
and it definitely impacted me.
Now, growing up in your
economic situation,
and then all of a
sudden selling Kayak--
and now you have $120 million.
What was going
through your mind?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
Again, when we sold
the company, first, we
took it public in July 2012.
And then we sold it
to Priceline in 2013.
I didn't do the math
first to figure out
how much money I made.
But I remember how much
money my assistant made.
And then when I did figure
out how much money I made,
it just felt surreal.
And it felt that I
didn't deserve the money
and I didn't deserve
to keep the money.
So I thought that the
money was something
that would temporarily
replace in my bank account,
but then I needed to find
things to do with the money.
Because money sitting in a bank
account is kind of useless.
That's not the point of money.
The point of money is
to conduct transactions.
And sitting in a bank account,
you're failing its objective.
So my goal is to invest
that money in nonprofits,
and try to find ones that
are meaningful to things
that I care about.
And hopefully I
will liquidate all
my Kayak money
for the nonprofits
I'm working with now.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
And once you did that--
the IPO event-- sorry,
once you did sell
the company, were you
getting like thousands
of requests of your time,
for donations?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I still do.
It's very painful.
I probably get 200
to 300 e-mails a day,
and I probably get a dozen
personal requests for help.
I had a woman today ask me
if I'd pay her mortgage.
And I get a dozen nonprofits
a day, soliciting me.
And it's painful to say no.
But the reality is I just
don't have the bandwidth
to engage with that many
dozens of people every day.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
And it's heart
breaking too, isn't it?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So can you talk to us about
your background with Haiti
and how you got
involved in there?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
Haiti has become a
big part of my life.
I first went to Haiti in
2003 but I've been many times
since then.
I was in Haiti a week ago.
I look at-- some
people describe Haiti
as the poorest country in
the Western hemisphere.
I don't think of it
like that at all.
I think of it as the country
with the most opportunity,
because my work is all
outside of Port Au Prince.
Port Au Prince is complete
insanity-- the capital.
And it's confusing and
I'm intimidated by it
because there's so much stuff--
crazy stuff-- going on there.
But when you go into the central
plateau or down south or up
north, there are very
simple communities
with very little technology.
Even like the
farming instruments
are in many cases,
100 years old.
It's not even modern
farming technology.
So being someone who
has resources and has
a network of people that
know about health care,
et cetera, et cetera, it's
been really fun for me
to work in Haiti because I get
extremely high ROI for money.
Like in Boston, I support a
number of projects in Boston,
and I know what $10,000 will
do for a non-profit in Boston.
But I also know
what $10,000 will
do for a nonprofit in Haiti
and it's transformational.
For $10,000, you can put
water in a village, where
people previously had
to walk hours and hours
to get clean water.
In many cases, they
would send the kids.
The kids wouldn't actually
go to the clean source.
They'd go for a river
that's contaminated.
And you can
transform health care
of a community of 1,000
people for just $10,000.
So it's kind of exciting.
My latest project
is in education.
And my project is
called Summits.
The website is summits.org.
And we run a network of 41
schools in the central plateau.
We have 350 teachers
and administrators
and we have 10,000 students.
And it's really exciting
to begin a project
where we took over these
schools which have been failing.
We have 10,000 students.
And if we can change the
lives of these students
and how they learn and change
lives of these teachers,
it's going to have massive
rippling positive effects
for that region and
hopefully for the country.
SPEAKER 1: Can you explain
the teaching techniques
you guys use in the classroom?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
So I don't have an
education background
but I've been learning
quite a bit about it
since I've been on this
project for the last two years.
I'll describe a scene
in the classroom--
when I was in the
classrooms in May,
I visited two different schools.
And then I was visiting
three other schools last week
in Haiti.
And in Mau, the way schools
operate in many developing
countries, the teacher is
at the front of the class,
the students all sit-in rows.
They may or may not have books.
And it's almost like
a call and repeat,
where the teacher will call
out a lesson and they'll write
on the chalkboard, and the
students just have to repeat
what the teacher said, in
some cases not complete;y
understanding what
the teacher is saying.
Particularly in Haiti--
this is a bit of a tangent--
but the way French is taught.
The native language is Creole.
Sometimes French is
taught because it's
the language of government,
but the teachers themselves
don't actually speak French
in these rural areas.
So it's kind of
ridiculous watching
them try to teach
French and they're
conjugating incorrectly, and
their pronunciation is bad.
And there's no books in French.
The call and repeat
thing just was not
a very good environment.
We worked with three
different groups
that we researched for a year.
We picked three groups to help
us completely change pedagogy
and content as well.
And then when I was in
the classroom last week,
the kids are all
sitting in circles now,
in all of the classrooms
in all of our 41 schools.
And the teachers
have been trained
that the best thing
they can do for teaching
is to get the students
talking to each other.
And so the teachers
now will lecture,
but then they ask the kids,
what do you think about that?
What do you think about that?
And they have the kids
interviewing each other
in the class.
And it was completely
transformational,
like from May to last
week to see that change.
And it was a result of a
teacher training program, that
took us a year to put in
place, but we executed on it
this summer.
It was pretty exciting.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
I mean, you're developing
a group of free thinkers
who are given the power
to actually talk, be
able to have the ability to
take part in their education
and not feel like
they're just going
to be just memorizing the same
facts over and over again.
Now, you talked about
meditation and Buddhism.
Have you guys practiced any
mindfulness in those classrooms
or experimented with anything?
PAUL ENGLISH: It's interesting.
One of the teachers who works
in the south area of Haiti
called Fond Blanc.
He's a physician and a teacher.
And he meditates.
In fact, the first time I
meditated with this guy,
it was very funny.
Dr. Pierre-- we were talking
one night about mindfulness.
And he said, would you like
to meditate with me tomorrow
morning?
And I said, I'd love to.
And he said, do
you want to start
at five o'clock or six o'clock?
And I said, six o'clock.
And he said, do you want to
do one hour of meditation
or two hours?
One hour.
This guy was hard core.
And there are people
in Haiti, as there
are in every country in
the world, who meditate.
And we're trying to figure
out how to bring meditation
into the schools.
There have been a couple
of little experiments,
but I'd like to bring it
formally into the school.
Realistically, I
think that's probably
January or next
September, because we
have a number of change
that we're doing this fall.
SPEAKER 1: Gotcha.
And do you have a regular
meditation practice yourself?
PAUL ENGLISH: I do
very simple meditation.
I meditate usually just for 15
minutes, sometimes 30 minutes,
in the morning.
More than meditation, I
do mindfulness exercises--
I think are almost as good as
meditation-- just making sure
that you're always
extremely present
and noticing people around
you and objects around you,
and not getting
lost in your head,
and trying to-- let me see.
One of my favorite
stories of mindfulness
is a Vietnamese
Buddhist I really
like named Thich Nhat Hahn.
In one of his books,
he told the story
where he had an American
Buddhist visiting him,
and Thich Nhat Hahn
had made him a dinner.
And after dinner, the
American took the dishes
to go to wash them,
and Thich Nhat Hahn
said to the American,
no, no, no, no.
Don't wash the dishes.
And he said, no, you've
made me this great meal.
I want to wash the dishes.
And Thich Nhat
Hahn said, but you
don't know how to wash dishes.
He said, of course I
know how to wash dishes.
I'm a bachelor.
I wash dishes in my
apartment all the time.
And Thich Nhat Hahn said, well,
why do you wash the dishes?
And the American,
in the presence
of this great Buddhist, tried
to think of some clever answer,
and said, well, we wash
the dishes to prepare,
to cleanse the plates, so that
another delicious meal can
be delivered tomorrow
in these same dishes
and Thich Nhat Hahn said, no,
you wash dishes to wash dishes.
And what he means is while
you're washing dishes,
you're supposed to
focus on just the flow
of the water and the suds.
And there are exercises like
that I've done now for maybe 10
or 15 years-- that
I try to focus
on pushing all of the
thought away another
than the thought of
the task at hand.
And those exercises
have helped me a lot,
particularly with
anger management.
I'm someone who had a lot
of anger management issues
when I was in my 20s.
And now, it's rare
that I get angry.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I noticed in the
book, you mentioned
that when you see brake
lights, you look at them
as the face of the Buddha.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
PAUL ENGLISH:
That's another one.
I also learned that one
from Thich Nhat Hahn.
I remember I was driving an
ex-girlfriend to the airport
in Boston-- Daria Logan--
there was crazy, crazy traffic.
And traffic doesn't impact me.
And she was shocked
that I wasn't
upset at all at the traffic.
And I remember telling her that
this other thing that I read
about Thich Nhat Hahn is when
you see that tail lights come
on in front of
you, it reminds you
of the smiling eyes of Buddha.
And you have the
incredible privilege
at that moment to breathe.
So there are things that
are stressful in our life
that we can turn into joy.
And it's just a decision.
I think getting angry at
someone is bringing cancer
upon yourself.
It's kind of like, imagine if
someone cut you off in traffic.
Would you, as a result
of that, hit yourself
in the head with a hammer?
No, because that would hurt.
But why get mad at them?
Because when you get mad
at them and yell at them
and swear at them, that's also
bringing damage to your body.
It's internal damage.
And so if you just
make that choice,
that if you recognize that
anger brings violence internal--
there's a Buddhist
saying that anger
is like drinking
poison and expecting
the other person to die.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And you have
a quote from Brenda
that used to say that.
She would say, anger
is an incredible gift
that someone is giving you.
It gives you an
opportunity to figure out
something about yourself.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
I think that's true.
SPEAKER 1: That's
a great reflection.
Going back to startups-- so
you started Blade and then
from there, you decided to
create a company called Lola.
Can you talk about Lola?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
So with Kayak, I spent 10
years of my life trying
to revolutionize online travel.
And with Lola, I'm
just what year one in,
but I'm guessing might
be another 10 year
project of trying to
revolutionize offline travel.
So offline travel means travel
booked actually on the phone,
like in a phone call.
And surprisingly to
most people in tech,
46% of travel booked
in the United States
is booked over the phone.
You get people call Marriott, or
Delta, or an old school travel
agent, or a corporate
travel agent,
a cruise specialists,
safari specialist--
there are many different
types of agents.
And that industry has had no
tech innovation in decades.
And so what Lola
is trying to do is
we believe that if you throw
out all the travel agent
software, which is a substantial
amount of technology,
and you rewrite it from scratch
and give travel agents tools
that they have never had before,
those tools can provide a user
experience that is impossible
to get through any other method.
And so what we've found
is that uses sometimes
want to talk on the phone.
Sometimes they want to message.
Sometimes they want to email.
And we have a mobile app that
allows you-- and will soon
allow you-- to do
more things like that.
So it's a multimodal app that
allows you to communicate
with Lola any way you want.
And there's a human travel
agent on the other end
that is doing all the research
and planning and booking
for you.
SPEAKER 1: And are
the travel agents
located in the United States?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
So the first 20 are located in
Boston next to the engineers
because I want them
to feel the pain.
I want the engineers to feel
the pain when things don't work
well for the travel agents.
The ultimate plan is to
let anyone in the world
apply to be a
travel agent on Lola
and have them go through
some extensive exams-- online
exams-- and video.
We just got video exam.
And then once we
verify their expertise,
we can plug them
into the platform.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, nice.
So they're kind of like their
own independent contractors
working there?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Because you
mentioned with Kayak,
you had like a red phone that
people could call directly.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
It was funny but I saw
something earlier today
that when I left Kayak the guy
who I promoted to take my job
is an extraordinary
CTO-- I think
he must have had a
list of 10 things
to change about the
company the day I left.
And one of them was he
unplugged the red phone.
The red phone-- I literally
had the phone number--
if you clicked the
help button on Kayak,
the help screen comes up
with a bunch of options.
And for 10 years
while I was there,
there was a phone
number as well.
And that phone number rang
the red phone on my desk.
And I bought a phone that
was particularly loud.
It had a mechanical ringer.
And I bought the
phone thinking it's
going to really annoy the
engineers, which was my intent.
And the engineers would say,
that's really effin loud.
That's really distracting.
And I would just say, there's
a very simple solution.
This is a two-part phone.
If you lift up this top
part, the ringing stops.
And then if you put that top
part to your head, and you say,
hello?
There'll be someone
on the other end that
will teach you something
about your product
that you don't know.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
PAUL ENGLISH: So to me,
phone calls and customers--
I feel like companies should be
paying customers to call them.
Because it's funny that
marketing organizations have
primary research budgets,
and yet people put these IBRs
and frequently asked questions
and all these systems
between customers
and the engineers.
Where I think that if you
let the engineers actually
talk to customers, you
can accelerate learning.
SPEAKER 1: You
mentioned in the book,
it says that you tried to--
TRACY KIDDER: He did mention.
He did--
SPEAKER 1: Mention, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
You tried to buy a lighthouse.
Can you explain that story?
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
Actually, why don't you
describe that story.
Yeah.
Because I was sort of manic
at the time, and I think
Tracy was sane at the time.
TRACY KIDDER: More or less.
More or less.
Well, as I recall,
there was a notice
of a lighthouse up for auction.
It was the most seaward
lighthouse in Boston Harbor.
That is right out in the
ocean on a pile of rocks
called Grave's Ledges.
Paul loves parties
and he wanted to make
a new kind of party place.
I saw the e-mails.
Anyway, the description
of the lighthouse
wasn't all that
encouraging though,
because it had no
plumbing, no electricity.
And to get to it,
which was really
unsafe to do in calm weather,
but to get to it-- to get
into the lighthouse, you had to
climb on a ladder 30 feet long.
And I was kind of
interested to imagine
the people in
their party clothes
looking down at
these crashing waves.
The next day, Paul awoke and
thought, what have I done?
That's the stupidest
thing I've ever done.
But I guess hypermania is not
entirely unusual in Boston
because someone bid
more for the lighthouse
and got him off the hook.
Most of Paul's fits of hypomania
were as harmless as that.
When I mentioned that story to
Brenda, your significant other,
she just laughed for about
five minutes and she said,
it's nothing.
What harm did that do?
Something good would
have come out of it.
I don't know.
I must say, hypomania is a
fascinating phenomenon to me.
I did some research on it
and I spoke to a great expert
on it-- and a
clinician researcher,
and I said, somehow I
can't quite explain it.
I kind of know when this guy is
about ti-- when this thing is
beginning to take over.
And he said, well,
that's perceptive of you.
I don't think I know
any clinicians who
deal with people who are subject
to hypomania, who wouldn't
tell you that it's contagious.
They would say it
was contagious,
in the sense that you feel it.
I think of a guitar
string being plucked
and the other instruments
sounding board, vibrating.
A sense for me of things
coming just a little too fast--
and the story I've
told which it seems
innocuous, but these
winter days-- I
remember these winter days
where Paul was off at a meeting.
He had about 10
meetings every day.
But get to a restaurant,
get our coats hung up,
everything's going OK.
And Paul says something and
I want to write it down,
and I write this down,
because I like to take notes.
And I look up and
suddenly somehow he's
in his winter coat.
And he's standing
there and he's smiling.
And he's saying very
pleasantly, ready to go?
It's just the way I think of it.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
The hypomanic stuff
I think has been
a contributor to my success.
Bipolar has the
downs and the ups.
And the downs for me were near
crippling when I was in my 20s.
I would spend a lot
of time housebound
and on the floor of my bedroom.
I couldn't even sleep on a bed.
It's hard to explain
why that was the case.
And luckily at some
point, I discovered
a med that works really
well for me for the downs.
I used to have
panic attacks a lot.
But I haven't experienced
any of the real downs
or panic attacks for
more than 10 years now.
But on the ups, the
tricky thing about it
is the meds that
I will get to work
for me, after about
a year on a new med,
my visualization of what happens
is the brain finally figures
out how to work its way around
the med and rewires itself.
And the med no longer works.
Then you begin this cross.
But the problem is when you go
through a manic phases, which
for me, last weeks at a
time, sometimes months,
it feels really, really good.
It feels very electrifying.
Like I can feel it in
my arms all the time.
And the problem with being manic
or hypomanic is left untreated,
you can do really stupid things.
And you're filled with
grandiosity and your mind
races.
People become really slow
and I have this perception
when I'm manic, that other
people just can't understand me
and they can't keep
up with me, which
I know is just the grandiosity
speaking when I'm saying--
and I pursue with vigor lots
of crazy different ideas
all the time.
And there's other downsides
of being manic as well.
I write large checks.
I hook up with people I
shouldn't be hooking up with.
There's a lot of things I do
when I'm totally manic that I
then end up later regretting.
But I think overall,
it's been really
useful as an entrepreneur to
have these weeks at a time
if not months of
this crazy energy.
SPEAKER 1: Do you have
like totems or things
you use to like
remind yourself, like
if you're caught in
this manic state,
like oh, I'm being
manic right now?
Maybe I need to take
a couple steps back.
Or is it--
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
A lot of it, I notice, for
some reason when I'm driving,
I'm very-- I notice
very strongly lighting.
I've always been
interested in lighting.
And I'll notice the
sides of buildings.
Lets say I'm driving
by a brick building.
I can almost tell what time it
is by the color of the brick
because the quality
of the sunlight
changes during the day.
And when I'm manic, the
brick sort of lights up
and it turns a different color.
And I just become really, really
perceptive of things around me.
And if there are
people in my car,
the people become
invisible and I just
focus on the grass
or different things
around me start
becoming electrifying.
And I don't know.
Have you have been
in a car accident?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
PAUL ENGLISH: You
know like a moment
where there's a collision, your
body jacks with adrenaline.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
PAUL ENGLISH: So when I'm high,
that last for days at a time.
And the first time it
started happening to me,
I was in my 20s.
It is a very
uncomfortable feeling.
It feels like something's
wrong with you
and you should go
to the hospital
because you're completely
jacked with adrenaline,
and there's no way to stop it.
But later, when you
learn to manage it,
it's kind of a fun thing.
I do know when these
incidents happen,
and I start with this-- I
call on fire-- many times
when I wake up first
thing in the morning,
I do know that I should
check with my psychiatrist,
and just say, if
I've been going days
at a time with very,
very little sleep,
I should probably
have a med check
and see if I need to do
something different just
to keep me from
going a little bit
too far where I
disconnect from reality,
I disconnect from people, and I
make really rash decisions that
are sometimes bad decisions.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And it seems as
time has gone on,
you've been able to
channel that energy
towards more constructive aims.
PAUL ENGLISH: Hopefully.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
PAUL ENGLISH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Well, thank you
guys very much for this.
I'm going to turn this
section to audience questions.
So if anyone has
audience questions,
feel free to come up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious in response
to that, have you ever
come across in your career,
the works of EF Schumacher--
Buddhist economic, small
is beautiful.
PAUL ENGLISH: I have.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
can say a little bit
about how his thoughts
reflect on your career.
And also, I'm curious
what do you teach or talk
about when you teach at
the Berklee School being
a musician?
PAUL ENGLISH: So I guest
lecture there are an innovation
and creativity.
I used to be a musician.
I'm not musician anymore.
But I know enough
about music that I
can speak to music students.
And we talk about that business.
Musicians are
actually entrepreneurs
because every business
every musician
has to create their living,
and most musicians I would say
are entrepreneurs.
It's all talk about
entrepreneur skills you need,
even if you're quote
unquote just a musician.
Entrepreneur work is
not just for engineers.
It's for anyone who's a
sole practitioner trying
to create a business.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so
much for joining us here.
TRACY KIDDER: You're welcome.
SPEAKER 1: Let's give
them a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]